make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin okay so there's been a lot
of talk recently about the illuminati in
the mcu like it just started blowing up
on youtube and i really didn't even know
why i was like why in the world
not even on youtube right like on social
media twitter and all that kind of stuff
i was like why in the world is everybody
talking about the illuminati well i went
to instagram
and looked up well actually i found him
through uh through tony uh tc does
comics but this uh this instagram
account called illumina nerdy which is
actually
really awesome you guys should check him
out uh he's pretty solid and has some
really cool stuff on there apparently he
breaks a lot of news things like that
apparently it's like kevin feige in them
are trying to find a way to put the
illuminati in the mcu so it's more or
less confirmed in the sense that like
they're working on it we just don't know
when exactly they're going to show up
and it got me thinking because one of
the big responses that i saw from people
was that if the illuminati are going to
be in the mcu then how can you do the
team without iron man but here's the
important thing to understand guys yeah
tony stark was part of the illuminati
but he was by no means the most
important person on the team
the benefit about the illuminati when it
was originally created by bendis and
when it was expanded upon and i think
improved by jonathan hickman during
avengers and new avengers is that
each member of the team had something to
offer that made them unique
so it wasn't like it's centered around
iron man right i mean he was a
leader you know insofar as you know
anybody could be a leader with a team
full of leaders but you don't really
need iron man in the marvel cinematic
universe to make the illuminati work the
real question
to ask here is what are the illuminati
and how do you put them in the mcu
the illuminati were basically this super
clandestine group
originally it consisted of reed
wrenchers of the fantastic four iron man
professor x doctor strange black bolt of
the inhumans and namor the submariner
now
black panther and captain america were
kind of this quirky little situation
that you had going on right so the
initial meeting of the
of the illuminati took place in wakanda
and it was done of course at the
permission of black panther because
nobody gets into the
kingdom of wakanda without black
panther's permission right otherwise
they end up getting killed or they
somehow manage to escape but they can
get turned into sound like ulysses claw
did which is really kind of weird but
the idea behind this
was that black panther was avidly
against it right he was
wildly against the idea of the
illuminati it was like no you do not
want to create some super secret
organization designed to safeguard the
world right this this is going to end
badly things like this
always end badly and it has ever since
the dawn of modern man
you don't want to do this the illuminati
did it anyway now the reason why i say
captain america is a bit quirky is
because captain america's involvement
with the illuminati didn't come
until jonathan hickman's avengers and
new avengers run that captain america
was part of the illuminati at one point
now it ended up being that his mind was
wiped and he was basically removed from
the team ah because of the fact that he
wasn't willing to destroy planets and
the the collapse of the multiverse and
so on and if you want to learn more
about that check out the avengers new
avengers playlist down in the
description really like the best marvel
comic book stories ever uh playlist down
in the description but captain america's
involvement was relatively short-lived
right so that's why it's that's why it's
a little quirky the idea was that this
this team came together as a result of a
conflict called the creed scroll war and
the creatures world war was a super
important event that took place in
marvel comics for a variety of reasons
one was because of the fact that in
terms of the publishing side it was like
the first
major cosmic crossover event that marvel
had that was done
on that kind of a scale it was huge at
the time and there are still comic book
fans today that hail it is one of the
greatest comic book stories ever told
spoiler alert it's not but it is a
pretty decent story you know nonetheless
the idea here was that each member of
the illuminati professor x of the x-men
read riches of the fantastic four so on
and so forth each of them had a piece of
information that if they had brought
their information together and combined
their resources preschool war
never would have gotten as close to
earth as it did right because it almost
laid waste to the entirety of the planet
and so the illuminati formed as
a kind of think tank and the sense that
each member would basically share
information with each other so that
everybody had a kind of complete picture
in terms of the various threats that
were facing earth and that if one of
those threats
seemed small they could compare their
information and find out it's actually a
much bigger threat later on down the
line uh and so with that in mind
putting the illuminati in the marvel
cinematic universe is a pretty
easy task right it's a pretty easy thing
to do the only difficulty that really
comes here
uh is from things like like neymar the
submariner or from things like professor
xavier of the x-men especially because
of the fact that the x-men have not been
established in the marvel cinematic
universe yet but there's a quick simple
work around for that so for somebody
like neymar the submariner that's simple
right atlantis was always a kingdom that
had you know a very difficult
relationship with us
with the surface world right it's like
aquaman and dc comics right atlantis
never liked the surface because they
always saw the surface as encroaching on
atlantean territory right and so it's
one of these things where atlantis was
always afraid that the service world was
going to either engage in warfare with
itself which would of course decimate
atlantis or
uh they would they would somehow invade
atlantis or something would pop off and
atlantis would be in danger
right and so name of the submariner went
through great lengths over the over the
course of his time
as as the ruler of atlantis to one plant
spies throughout the world
and then two to become part of the
illuminati in order to kind of keep an
eye on the surface world
it's the same reason why black panther
joined the avengers to spy on everybody
right to make sure they weren't going to
become a credible threat to wakanda it's
kind of cool like
and it's a little bit different in the
mcu but in the comics black panther
would set the world on fire before he
would let harm come to wakanda right
like he would he would go toe-to-toe
with every single avenger and he would
kill them all if he had to in order to
keep wakanda safe right he's a king
first and an avenger second
it's a it's one of the coolest elements
of his character the idea with with
neymar that's pretty straightforward you
simply just say half the life in the
universe was blinked out which included
half the life on earth during the events
of avengers in game and name while the
submariner
doesn't want his people to struggle in
that way again and so even if the
alliance with humanity is
is tenuous at best he becomes part of
the illuminati in order to make sure
that a threat like that doesn't occur
again
right so that's why we haven't really
seen him before because it's one of the
things where it's like you stay away i
stay away
but now i have a reason to get involved
in what you're doing that kind of a
situation right it's a little thin
and you could we could probably find a
way to sort of cook the books and make
it work in
a stronger way but it would serve its
purpose right it would allow us to
achieve that
the trickiest thing here is professor x
right professor x of the of the x-men
how do we get him in the marvel
cinematic universe if the x-men have not
been introduced yet i made a video
previously where i talked about how to
put mutants in the mcu and what i did is
i came up with this idea that was a
combination of what happened in the
ultimate universe
along with the main marvel universe and
because of the fact that the
introduction of the mcu was so close
knit with those two things we can kind
of leave out the comic book portion and
just go straight to what i would do in
the movies all you would really say here
is that uh that captain america as we
know was frozen in ice at the end of
captain america the first avenger
and and the whole idea is okay uh
captain america was just believed to
have been dead right alongside bucky
bones what we also know is that around
that time
that's when hydra slowly began to start
taking control of shield right it
started with arnhem zola being taken
prisoner and then slowly recruiting
people to his cause to the point where
hydra kind of had this little inner
circle inside of shield and then started
growing outward from there to the point
that shield was completely and totally
controlled by hydra on almost every
single level
the only people who didn't know were
either you know agents who
who hydra made no attempt to contact to
try to turn or like
staffers right like the guy from the
mail room who's like delivering your
mail or like the chick who's getting
coffee or something like that right
whatever the case happened to be
and so as a result of that what we can
say here is that in the aftermath of the
perceived death of captain america
uh you know shield was content with
going on and just doing its thing right
you know just kind of doing whatever it
was that they were doing maybe hunting
for steve rogers who really knows
because peggy carter refused to believe
he was dead i don't know doesn't really
matter but
hydra was hell bent on the idea of
creating more steve rogers they saw
potential there they sought
the potential for captain america and
said hey look if we can create super
soldiers that are loyal to us
right there they believe in hydra's
ideologies then like we can have our own
army of captain americas and who's gonna
stand against us right who's gonna be a
threat that can go against us i mean
sure
they can take out one or two captain
americas you know they can take out a
dozen maybe a couple dozen
they cannot take out 3 000 captain
americas right like just
a huge fighting force right imagine the
entire united states army was composed
of super soldiers and all of them
believed in hydra's ideologies
they could conquer the country like that
right it would it would it would happen
so fast and so as a result of the fact
the serum
was lost when abraham erskine died in
captain america the first avenger the
guy who basically gave steve rogers the
super soldier serum because of the fact
that he died and the
the details of the serum were lost with
him all hydra could do was just guess
right they could just like guess and
experiment and that kind of a thing and
so this basically leads to the
introduction of
james hallett and james hallett as as
some of you guys may know
also goes by the name of wolverine and
the idea is that he was basically
brought in by whatever manner and
whatever means we can use the main
marvel universe version and say he was
part of like team x which was basically
just like this uh this cold war era
you know black ops wet work team that
would like you know operate on behalf of
the united states government they could
there
think of it like mission impossible but
instead of tom cruise you got you know
wolverine that's more or less what the
team was but hydra ends up taking
wolverine and you know with the
intention of like giving them
the newest variant of the super soldier
serum but along the way discover that he
has a gene
that if it's activated can give him
powers and they activate the gene
wolverine's got a healing factor they
bond adamantium to his skeleton
go forward from there now the way that
we explain that gene comes off the heels
of the eternals film and we say that in
the eternals movie much like the main
marvel universe eternals showed up on
earth they modified the genes of a
portion of early uh of early man
and uh one third of those guys went
forward as eternals one third went
forward as deviants the other third went
forward and their genes would manifest
at some future point in time and it
simply just happened to be the humanity
got a hold of wolverine
before the genes were supposed to
manifest right maybe they were supposed
to manifest in like the year 5000
and wolverine was discovered and the
gene was discovered in like 1968 or
something along those lines whatever
date we choose to assign to it and so
what you basically do is you say that
that hydra activates that gene wolverine
goes through the whole weapon x process
he gets the adamantium because you know
the claws and all that kind of stuff you
know and he goes forward from there
and they you know by by whatever manner
and whatever means the activation
process is basically synthesized and
spread across the world and that
basically leads to all these individuals
out there with a mutant gene
suddenly developing powers it was you
know in the ultimate universe that's how
it was done
and so we basically just say that like
charles xavier was essentially just a
regular guy right he was just a normal
human walking around doing whatever it
was that he was doing and then like when
this activation process took place
whatever it was then like he suddenly
was bestowed upon you know the soda with
his powers or whatever the case happened
to be but basically this brings charles
xavier into the marvel cinematic
universe
and then as a result you know charles
xavier was there whether he was human or
mutant doesn't really matter but charles
xavier was there
when like half the earth population was
destroyed by thanos
and that's the entire basis behind why
the illuminati exist
the illuminati basically looked at the
events of infinity war in avengers
in-game and say
we cannot let a credible threat like
that happen to earth again
we have to prevent that from happening
so we're going to operate in secret and
we're going to share information with
each other so that we never really have
to worry about that we can kind of nip
this in the bud so that if it requires
the attention of all of our respective
teams then we can bring them together if
it doesn't and we can solve that problem
on our own then we'll take care of that
the problem with the illuminati is that
they had that idea you know the the
first thing they did is after they
formed they went to the the scroll home
world or at least what was left of the
scroll home world after galactus
destroyed it
and um they told the scroll emperor at
the time don't come don't bring your war
to earth right like we don't want any
part of that leave us alone or the next
time there's going to be consequences
and repercussions the scrolls basically
knocked them out uh copied their dna and
then sent them back to earth and then he
ended up getting a secret invasion where
you find out the whole reason why the
scrolls were copying the dna of
superheroes was to replace them
right with scroll duplicates people who
could shape shift and and look like
superheroes it was pretty cool it was a
pretty cool story if not a little bit
confusing at times but that's how you
put the illuminati in the marvel
cinematic universe right like so many
other things that i hope you would see
in the first phase or two after the
events of infinity war and avengers
in-game you build off that story right
it's a great way to pay tribute to the
last 10 years while also starting
something new right so uh let me know
what you guys think down in the comments
section if you are new here to comments
explained make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob for if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like i will catch you all
later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
you